in today's it on your side how to help
your high school athlete connect with
coaches maybe even secure a college
scholarship we talked to the founder of
a mobile platform with that goal and the
best part it's free
we've seen incredible success stories
connor dietz is the founder of gmtm
short for game time an interactive
social network like linkedin but this
platform is specifically for the sports
industry connecting athletes with
opportunities throughout their career
regardless of income geography or
background
eighteen-year-old mason muir of
henderson recently signed up on the
platform as a point guard and shooting
guard for liberty high school in west
coast select he wants to make as many
connections as possible i obviously want
to play at the highest division in
college
but my main goal is to take as far as i
can for mason and many athletes during
the pandemic it was a challenge they
couldn't play couldn't tour any
universities or meet with coaches in
person but through gmtm athletes have
the opportunity to do some of that
virtually if an athlete in california
doesn't you know maybe they don't have
the resources to be able to fly
right to pennsylvania to a d3
you know university they can still get
in front of that university and still
get in front of those coaches and
connect with them in an authentic way
through gpm
mason continues to play some tournaments
around las vegas and california all the
while busy checking his account
definitely excited because i've had
coaches reach out hoping for that
connection that will solidify his future